bienvenidos ahora haremos varios
problemas de movimiento de proyectiles
pues creemos que ustedes aprenderán más
bien lo alguien resolver y explicaremos
alta problemas y fórmulas aunque quizá a
mi manera de explicar pueda ser algo
extraña y puede que los haya confundido
un poco de los vídeos anteriores así que
ahora espero poder deshacer el daño que
haya podido hacer o mejor aún que
ustedes hayan aprendido de mis errores
ahora comencemos con un problema general
supongamos que estoy en la cima de un
precipicio y yo me lanzo en lugar de
dejar caer algo mejor me dejo caer yo no
nos preocupemos de mi movimiento lateral
supongamos que caigo directo hacia abajo
y pensemos que nada malo me va a pasar
digamos que la cima del precipicio mi
velocidad inicial que le llamamos vi era
de cero no tenía velocidad ya que estaba
yo quieta antes de dejarme caer y
digamos que en el fondo del precipicio
mi velocidad final
es de 100 metros por segundo
y la pregunta es cuál es la altura del
precipicio creo que ahora es buen
momento para explicar es la noción de
dirección en la velocidad entonces mi
velocidad final es menos voy a ponerlo
en otro color para que se note menos 100
metros por segundo
aquí estoy suponiendo que una velocidad
hacia arriba es positiva y hacia abajo
es negativa y como estoy cayendo por eso
tiene este menos 100 metros por segundo
que indica que voy hacia abajo aunque
también podemos asumir lo contrario lo
opuesto de que hacia abajo es positivo y
hacia arriba negativo pero no es el
problema vamos a acordar que hacia abajo
es negativo
así que si establecimos que hacia abajo
es negativo y la gravedad siempre nos
jala hacia abajo entonces diremos que la
aceleración la aceleración va a ser
igual a la gravedad que es igual a menos
metros por segundo al cuadrado aunque la
constante de la gravedad es de 9.8
metros por segundo al cuadrado vamos a
redondear la aquí a 10 para facilitar
los cálculos siempre que un problema
involucra algo cayendo o saltando en
este planeta usaremos esta constante
gravitatoria la pregunta es bueno tengo
mi velocidad inicial y mi velocidad
final justo al dar contra el suelo cuál
es la distancia recorrida en esta
circunstancia que representa la
distancia bueno aquí va a ser la altura
del precipicio como lo vamos a calcular
podemos la única fórmula que conocemos
sobre la distancia aunque de hecho es el
cambio en la distancia esta fórmula la
expresamos el cambio en la distancia
delta de o la diferencia en la distancia
es igual a la velocidad promedio por el
cambio en el tiempo aquí velocidad
promedio no se usa mucho cuando la
velocidad es instantánea o constante
pero aquí la velocidad no es constante
fue aumentando de 0 a 100 metros por
segundo aunque normalmente asumimos que
comenzamos con una distancia igual a
cero y de igual manera asumimos que el
tiempo inicial es igual a cero entonces
nos queda que la distancia va a ser
igual a la velocidad promedio por el
tiempo ya que la distancia inicial es
cero y el tiempo inicial es cero quizá
más adelante veamos situaciones en las
que el tiempo inicial no es cero o la
distancia inicial no es cero y así
usaremos esta fórmula del cambio en la
distancia o el cambio en el tiempo esta
es la fórmula que conocemos de distancia
es igual a la velocidad por el tiempo
vemos que podemos calcular la velocidad
promedio porque tenemos la velocidad
inicial y la velocidad final entonces
voy a poner aquí en este color mi
velocidad promedio y la vamos a calcular
velocidad promedio bueno mi velocidad
promedio es mi velocidad final
mi velocidad inicial entre 2 ya que
tengo sólo dos valores así que voy a
promediar estos dos valores
esto es igual bueno queremos que mi
velocidad final era de menos 100 este
menos me indica el sentido hacia dónde
está la velocidad y mi velocidad inicial
era cero menos cero entre dos esto es
igual a menos 100 entre 2 pues va a ser
igual a menos 50 y las unidades de la
velocidad metros por segundo menos 50
metros por segundo
esa es mi velocidad promedio bueno ya
encontré un dato y también por otra
parte tenemos que el cambio en la
velocidad voy a ponerlo de otro color yo
sé que el cambio en la velocidad es
igual a la velocidad final menos la
velocidad inicial y esto a su vez es
igual a la aceleración por el tiempo
aquí t el tiempo lo voy a poner naranja
y aquí también conozco estos valores de
manera que esta velocidad final menos
velocidad inicial
es igual a menos 100 metros por segundo
que es la velocidad final menos la
velocidad inicial que 0 metros por
segundo y esto es igual a la aceleración
y aquí tengo que la aceleración es menos
10 metros por segundo al cuadrado menos
10 metros por segundo al cuadrado por el
tiempo bueno simplificamos esto y me va
a quedar menos 100 metros por segundo es
igual a menos 10 metros por segundo al
cuadrado por el tiempo ahora quiero
despejar el tiempo entonces tengo que
dividir a ambos lados de esta igualdad
entre menos 10 metros por segundo al
cuadrado tiempo es igual a menos 100
metros por segundo entre menos 10 metros
por segundo al cuadrado simplificamos
con esto esto con esto estas unidades
me van a quedar este metro se va con
este metro este segundo se va con uno de
estos y me va a quedar que el tiempo es
igual a diez segundos aquí bueno el
tiempo no puede ser negativo esto es
imposible por lo tanto el tiempo siempre
va a ser positivo creo que algún día se
encuentre una máquina para viajar en el
tiempo y se pueda regresar al pasado
pero bueno estos problemas que son
normalitos el tiempo siempre va a ser
positiva ahora ya tengo entonces la
velocidad promedio y tengo el tiempo
pues puedo calcular la distancia estos
valores
del tiempo y la velocidad promedio los
pongo en esta fórmula la distancia es
igual a la velocidad promedio que era
de menos 50 metros por segundo y esto
está multiplicado por el tiempo el
tiempo es de 10 segundos esto es igual
se van estos segundos de acá quedan
metros menos 50 por 10 menos 500 metros
esta es mi distancia y este símbolo
negativo bueno que significa una
distancia negativa pues como tal una
distancia negativa lo único que nos
indica es que la dirección hacia donde
se recorrió esta distancia fue en este
caso quedamos que todo lo negativo iba
hacia abajo la distancia fue hacia abajo
por eso es este menos indica la
dirección de esta distancia si fuera
positivo la distancia y díaz hacia
arriba en esta convención que tenemos de
este problema en particular así que
queremos ver esto un poquito más claro
bueno vamos a dibujar aquí el precipicio
este es el precipicio en este punto
antes de dar el salto tenemos que la
distancia es ser mi distancia inicial
inicial es igual a cero y aquí bueno
queremos que saltamos se recorre toda
esta distancia y aquí mi distancia final
justo antes de dar contra el suelo
distancia final es igual a menos 500
metros de aquí acá la dirección fue
hacia abajo por eso es este menos indica
una distancia negativa y eso es muy
interesante si ustedes están en un
precipicio de 500 metros más o menos del
tamaño de un rascacielos si saltan de un
lugar así asumiendo que no hay
resistencia del aire al final tendrían
una velocidad de 100 metros por segundo
muy rápido digamos mejor que lanzamos
una moneda que por ser pequeña casi no
tendrá resistencia al aire pero es algo
que ustedes no deben hacer porque como
vimos va a tener una velocidad muy
fuerte y si le da a alguien lo puede
matar y no queremos darle malas ideas a
las personas malas
pero es interesante que la física nos
permita resolver este tipo de problemas
en el siguiente vídeo continuaremos
resolviendo problemas y espero que
ustedes se den cuenta que todo se reduce
a la velocidad promedio el cambio en la
velocidad que es aceleración por el
tiempo y el cambio en distancia es igual
al cambio del tiempo multiplicado por la
velocidad promedio nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo